We recently did a frequently asked questions
video where we mentioned that James, our master
of microscopes, was on the lookout for a super
rare ciliate with retractable tentacles called
Thysanomorpha.
This video is not a surprise announcement
that we’ve found one.
The Thysanomorpha remains elusive…for now.
But it turns out that thysanomorpha is not
the only super rare ciliate with retractable
tentacles.
What you’re looking at right now might not
immediately stand out.
You’ve got a sea of green organisms, and
then in the middle is a clear-ish oval.
And that oval is what we’re going to talk
about today.
Because over the course of three years, James’
many, many excursions into different watery
sources have turned up only three of them.
And as rare as the species is, we think the
footage he’s taken might be even harder
to come by.
The organism is called actinobolina, and it
showed up in a paper that a ciliate scientist
sent to James titled “Protozoa of Especial
Interest from Van Cortlandt Park, New York”
written by Gary N. Calkins.
The paper was an old one, published in 1901.
And if you haven’t been able to tell yet,
we love old papers like this.
They’re often written in a way that feels
a lot more casual than the way academic papers
are structured today.
It can feel like you’re reading somebody’s
journal entry or a travel blog that just happens
to contain important biological insight.
Calkins’ paper even starts with an extended
description of Van Cortlandt Park, complete
with railway directions and instructions on
how to reach the exact pond he sampled from.
So James read this delightful paper, which
includes an extended passage of the actinobolina
in action.
And the next morning, he found one!
We mentioned that he’s found only three
actinobolina in three years.
This is the third one, found the morning after
reading Calkins’ paper.
When James observed his first actinobolina,
he didn’t yet know how rare they were.
And his second actinobolina died quickly,
likely due to some kind of temperature shock.
So with this third member of the species,
James made sure to take extra care to keep
it alive and follow it around so he could
observe as much as possible.
Now, what makes the actinobolina so notable
are the tentacles lining its body.
They can be a little difficult to make out
from far away, but you can see the faint lines
of them surrounding the body.
With great magnification though, you can start
to see the bundles of cilia and tentacles
a bit better.
The tentacles can reach to around 2.5 times
the length of the organism’s diameter when
fully outstretched.
But even more cool than how far the tentacles
go out is how far in they go--like when the
actinobolina needs to move around and doesn’t
want some cumbersome extensions getting in
the way.
And when it’s zipping around the microcosmos,
the actinobolina’s cilia seem to have more
of a vibration to them than the usual wave-like
stroke associated with cilia.
In fact, they kind of resemble flagella more
than cilia.
But we don’t know much more about why or
how this movement works.
In his description of actinobolina, Calkins
writes, “It is when the animal is quiet
that it takes in food.
It remains for hours, sometimes, without giving
a sign of feeding, but the tentacles are stretched
out to their greatest length and it appears
merely waiting for something to come."
We don’t know if he meant for it to sound
as ominous as it does, but it certainly feels
appropriate for a tentacled predator.
Part of the fun of reading these old papers
is getting to see how well these observations
made by scientists over a century ago match
up to what we can see now.
It’s like exchanging letters with the past,
and our little actinobolina is the courier.
And it’s all even more exciting for us in
this case because as far as we can tell, not
many people have gotten footage of the actinobolina
in the midst of a hunt.
But while Calkins may not have had the technology
we have today to capture what he saw, he did
provide detailed descriptions that line up
nicely, starting with the surprisingly particular
tastes of the actinobolina.
Organisms pass and pass, but nothing tempts
the hunter until a specific prey comes along:
the unsuspecting ciliate called Halteria.
The Actinobolina stabs it with a tentacle,
which is loaded with a toxicyst at the end
to immobilize the prey.
And then the tentacle draws the food in, to
its inevitable end.
The actinobolina digests its meal, but as
Calkin himself said, it is insatiable.
So it retracts its tentacles and leaves, seeking
out a new spot to stretch out and ensnare
its next meal.
And here it is again, catching another Halteria
with its tentacles.
Using the word “tentacle” makes the actinobolina
sound like an octopus.
But watching the hunt in action, it looks
more like a porcupine with its quills fully
extended.
But a porcupine that uses its quills to skewer
meals instead of protect itself, and then
it retracts the quills so it can rush on to
the next spot.
We might be testing the limits of our comparisons
right now.
But that’s okay.
According to our calculations, we’ve got
about a year until our next actinobolina.
So when that rolls around, we’ll be ready
with some new ones.
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds
us.
And thank you as always to all of the people
on the screen right now.
These are our patrons on Patreon, and right
now, we’re pushing to get to $5,000 a month
which is when we’ll be getting a brand new
objective, that’s a lens for the bottom
of the microscope, for our DIC microscope
If you want to see more from our Master of
Microscopes James Weiss, check out Jam & Germs
on Instagram, and if you want to see more
from us, there’s always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby.